pour organiser les relations entre les
différents individus qui composent la
société les états modernes et
démocratiques ont mis en place toute une
série de lois et de règlements pour
assurer la bonne cohésion et la bonne
vie en société
lorsque des individus ou des personnes
morales ne sont pas d'accord elles
peuvent saisir la justice civile pour
trancher le litige
dans le cas où un individu commet une
infraction différents lois et règlements
la justice deviendra alors pénal il y
aura décision de la culpabilité ou non
de l'individu et de la mise en place de
peines
cette vidéo propose aujourd'hui de faire
un tour le point sur les différentes
ailes de justice qui peuvent être
appliqués une infraction a été commise
la personne est traduite en justice le
juge peut décider différentes choses
tout d'abord si la personne n'est pas
reconnue coupable des actes qui lui sont
reprochés qui lui étaient reprochés le
juge va la quitter l'acquittement c'est
simplement le fait de reconnaître la
personne comme innocente peut y avoir
aussi une extinction de l'action
publique en cas de décès de la personne
ou aussi il ya prescription des faits
c'est à dire qu'il ya trop longtemps que
les faits ont été commis et donc on juge
qu'il n'est plus pertinent de poursuivre
la procédure pénale dans le cas où la
procédure a été très longue et très
laborieuse la justice le juge peut
décider qu'il y à une simple déclaration
de culpabilité c'est à dire qu'on
déclare l'accusé coupable mais il n'y a
pas de peine qui est décidée le
prononcer peut être suspendue c'est à
dire que le juge décide de ne pas
statuer de ne pas décider d'une peine et
de remettre cette décision à plus tard
c'est souvent assorti de conditions qui
vont faire que l'accusé va devoir faire
certaines choses pendant le délai durant
lequel la décision est suspendue comme
par exemple suivre une formation ou ne
pas fréquenter certaines personnes
certains lieux
c'est ce qu'on appelle une suspension
probatoire l'accusé doit faire preuve de
certains de certaines choses et le juge
décidera plus tard des peines et de la
décision qu'ils prendront
il peut y avoir bien sûr une peine
privative de liberté c'est-à-dire une
près une peine à prester dans un
établissement un tablissements
pénitentiaire autrement dit une prison
la durée peut être mariable et dans
certains cas le tribunal d'application
des peines qui est le la magistrature
qui va suivre
l'accusé ou la personne reconnue
coupable pendant l'exécution de sa peine
peut décider que cette privation de la
liberté se fera par surveillance
électronique par exemple ça peut être
dans certains cas le ministre de la
justice qui doit décider et pour prendre
sa décision
il peut y avoir une peine de travail
l'accusé la personne reconnue coupable
devra pas rester pendant un certain
nombre d'heures un travail d'utilité
publique pour une asbl ou pour l'état
ça peut être rejoindre les murs d'un
home travail et dans les espaces verts
il peut y avoir aussi la déclaration
d'un sursis c'est à dire que la peine
est prononcée mais on n'applique pas
tout de suite
on va laisser un délai durant lequel la
personne peut éventuellement se
rattraper enfin il peut y avoir une
amende qui va être décidé à côté de
toutes ces peines principal il peut y
avoir des peines accessoires qui sont
décidés comme tout d'abord la
confiscation des biens donc que ça soit
l'objet de l'infraction comme par
exemple de largeur en faux ou des images
à caractère pédopornographique
voilà ces éléments vont être confisquée
évidemment il peut y avoir aussi une
confiscation de biens qui aurait permis
l'infraction comme par exemple du
matériel pour cambrioler une autre peine
accessoire à la publication la décision
qui va être rendu public
il peut y avoir aussi une destinée à une
destitution de certains titres comme par
exemple des titres de noblesse ou
certaines fonctions comme un titre de
notaire par exemple
cela ressemble fort à une autre peine
accessoire qui est la déchéance de
certains droits vous pas vous pourrez
par exemple plus être éligible c'est à
dire vous présenter à des élections si
vous avez été instituée de vos droits
politiques
vous pourrez aussi le plus exercer
certaines professions dans la fonction
publique qui nécessite une certaine
qualité de vos droits
il peut y avoir également une
interdiction professionnelle dans
certains milieux on peut y vont
évidemment penser à une situation où une
personne qui serait accusée d'actes est
reconnu coupable d'actes pédophiles ne
puisse plus rester dans des milieux liés
à la jeunesse par exemple
enfin une dernière peine accessoire et
la mise à disposition en plus de la
peine principale
on peut à ce moment-là mettre la
personne reconnue coupable à disposition
du tribunal d'application des peines
pour une période allant de 5 à 15 ans et
ça c'est possible pour les personnes qui
ont commis des actes particulièrement
grave et qui peuvent troubler leur
propose maintenant un petit tableau
récapitulatif pour faire le point sur
tous ces éléments ce tableau est
directement téléchargeables sur la
société qui est en lien sur la vidéo
youtube
je vous remercie de votre attention et
de votre intérêt pour cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas le pouce bleus si vous
avez apprécié vous pouvez toujours vous
abonner à cette chaîne qui vous
proposera de nombreuses vidéos sur les
concepts et les bases des sciences
sociales
alors je suis un généraliste je ne suis
pas juriste donc si vous êtes juriste et
que vous pensez qu'il ya certains points
qui peuvent être développées ou préciser
les commentaires sont bien sûr à votre
disposition et je me ferai un plaisir
d'y répondre ou de modifier les éléments
qui auraient été mis en avant par vous
même
j'ai un vous remercie encore une fois et
à très bientôt